all right hello everyone my name is
sally we're here at cube con barcelona
and with me today is aaron creek and
berger he has a lot of hats that he
wears
he's a Google engineer he is on the
kubernetes steering committee and he's
been involved with a lot of kubernetes
releases aaron can you talk a little bit
about the releases that you've been
involved with and how they've evolved
over time sure I've been involved with
kubernetes releases since kubernetes was
at version 1.4 and at the beginning it
was just sort of a select few google
people who were hardcore enough and had
the right privileges to make this happen
and over time I saw the release process
gradually handover more and more control
to the community
I started out writing release notes you
know attempting to sort of reverse
engineer a coherent narrative out of
this chaotic open source process and
over time grew into other roles such as
you know issue triage keeping track of
how do we actually know what's happening
within the release and make sure the
right things are being focused on to to
see I signal you know how do we make
sure that a given kubernetes release is
actually healthy and ready to ship out
the door and that sort of culminated in
me acting as a release lead for
kubernetes 1:14 which I was especially
proud of because it was the the release
with the most stable enhancements out of
any kubernetes release and it was also
the first release where the community
agreed to use the kubernetes enhancement
proposal process or cap process to to
ship features which to me was really a
sign of just how mature the release
process has come and while I was doing
this I was assisted by a team of over 40
people serving in 13 different roles to
ensure that mostly all I had to do was
watch you know everything proceed super
smoothly and it culminated in me getting
to create this this cat t-shirt here
where every release team member gets a
piece of swag as sort of you know the
honorary badge of running the release
for three months and my piece of swag
was was quatre Nettie's you know three
cats looking up at the kubernetes logo
sort of like three Wolf Moon very cool
and so you mentioned how this process
has become better and
is more community owned there's a lot of
other work going on to improve the
kubernetes community can you talk about
some of that sure
back when kubernetes first started we we
weren't even sort of very organized in
terms of what we were doing it was just
some very driven companies and
contributors trying to push code out as
quickly as possible and we gradually
realized that we needed to get
like-minded people together to talk
about different areas that they were
interested in coordinating on so I used
to work with a guy named Bob Boyce who I
worked with him to co-found seek
scalability the first special interest
group I then worked to co-found the
second special interest group called
seek testing all about the testing of
kubernetes to make sure that that worked
well today we now have over 31 special
interest groups and we've also created
working groups that are collaborations
between special interest groups so we
fairly sort of federated out and
empowered the decision-making process
for this open source community and at
the same time we've been very
intentional about focusing on inclusion
and diversity through this whole process
taking a look at how we engage with our
with our community members and with our
contributors and looking at the examples
that we set to ensure that we're acting
and as inclusive a manner as possible
sort of setting up work and describing
roles to make it easier to onboard
people who are maybe intimidated or
overwhelmed by contributing to a project
that is it was large and fast moving as
kubernetes so i've really been happy to
see that that sort of payoff and I think
that attitude has been reflected in in
the keuken conference you know that sort
of hangs around kubernetes where there's
there these diversity scholarships that
happen each year and you sort of see
this nice exponential growth curve I
thought it was really neat to hear the
story today of Nikita Draganov who
described her journey from sort of
college student to to owner of very
fundamental parts of the kubernetes
codebase today and you know she got
there by sort of showing up to one of
these special interest groups feeling
like she was heard she found a mentor
who was willing to help her out
and she managed to get to the to the
first to her first coupon by way of a
diversity scholarship to really
experience all the wonderful stuff that
this community has to offer I also
thought another really great thing I saw
in this coupon was sort of more of a
focus on on mental health
realizing that because this is such a
large and overwhelming open source
project that some people can maybe maybe
burn out or maybe feel a little
uncertain of themselves it's actually
tweeted about this at the last Kubb con
it was super exhausting to me actually
like I think I gave six talks throughout
a week there's a lot and I said hey I
think we really need to talk about
burnout and I heard back from like over
200 people sharing with me their
experiences and and what they were up to
and what they were coming up against and
some of the the constructive criticism
that they had to offer both me as an
individual as well as the conference
organizers to improve this and you know
today I just came out of a mental health
talk to hear how you know members
companies who contribute to all of the
projects here that are hosted by the C
and CF are taking a mental health very
seriously that's awesome so it sounds
like there's a lot of really great work
going on to make the kubernetes
community not only more diverse but also
more sustainable make sure that we can
continue to do all the great work that
we've been doing so thank you for all
your work on that last question what are
you looking forward to here at Q con
this year well so like I said earlier I
think the thing I was most looking
forward to was getting to see that that
mental health talk and hear the like I
stayed I stayed after the talk and heard
so many community members ask questions
and follow-up questions afterwards and
that was that was my second talk was
just hearing everybody else engaged and
following that conversation
I'm also selfishly really interested in
my panel at the end of Thursday to talk
about burnout and how we can leverage
this community to set better norms for
self-care
things like that cool well thank you so
much for your time Aaron oh thanks a lot
Saad great to be here